i already said hello
[Music]
remember the name we carry around isn't
only meant to make others say how good
we are in the field but also how good we
are out of the field
that's how you make the difference
where are you going
to vienna
and what will you be doing there
a soccer tournament
with strong teams
yes
bayer munich
locomotive moscow salzburg
how old are you
nine
eight
june 1st
airport a team of eight or nine-year-old
boys is leaving followed by a staff
worthy of a champions league team
sit down everybody stand up when i call
your name
there had never been anything like
it baby soccer players around the world
playing international tournaments all
the time considering all age groups
that's the 30th flight in the 70th
tournament abroad
it's quite similar to our motto the way
we view soccer this song immediately
made me think of you
[Music]
hooray for freedom
foreign
russian revolution inconredo
are you tired
yes
it's almost midnight when we arrived in
vienna with young lugano soccer players
in order not to miss their afternoon in
school they took a late evening flight
hunger and fatigue however
do not erase the thrill for the
adventure they are experiencing
a dream adventure they will face world
famous teams and discover a new big city
do you think that dome is round
no
so what is it
it's oval and there were sensational
construction back in the 1700s
so this guy started making a concoction
with chocolate it's called sasha torte
the trip lasts three days and the
program includes a visit to the city as
well
all expenses are covered even the tour
guide showing the kids the beauty of the
venus 1700s but who pays for all of this
how many players do we have in the first
team of lugano
how many in the champions league
this continuity is not good for us
continuity means continuity of
excellence and this is our way of
thinking
how much money do you invest in a youth
department in the lugano team
more or less one million a year
there's a russian gentleman who is
investing a lot of money to create here
the most important soccer school in the
world
his name is
to meet his goal he hired about 70
people
ranging from collaborators to coaches
mostly snatching them from ac milan and
other big italian clubs
and now he wants to involve the entire
casino
in my opinion is a perfect place for
soccer
there are many fields the weather is
beautiful there are many kids
we just have to involve those who still
don't play soccer
especially i'm often asked if our main
competitor is hockey or basketball but
no
our competitor today is called ipad
ipad
i like party playstation
children don't do sports if we engage
them from a very young age and motivate
them with a quality project and with a
dream of reaching the highest levels we
will have the numbers
um
[Music]
the lugano project is an ambitious
project that started from the will of
our president leenoy novoselsky
he gave us coaches and to the entire
staff starting from the organizational
aspect the chance to live a dream and
build it together while training players
of international levels
comes from ac milan
for years he has dealt with youth
academics all over the world
he is now the coach of the whole youth
department
which side of the foot do we use for the
kangoo exercise front or back
games and exercises to stimulate motor
skills and coordination qualities that
are increasingly lacking among children
that's the wednesday soccer school where
children age four to five years and over
and is the right age to start becoming a
good soccer player
there are already 650 young people
between 6 and 15 years old involving in
this project between soccer school and
competitive activities for children
about 50 of them come from italy but how
did it get to this i decided to meet mr
novoselski at his house to get to know
him better
i don't live in lugano as i usually say
i live in flight on planes every week i
go to russia for work then i come back
here for the weekend or a long weekend
weekend all weekend long
12 years ago our friends suggested us to
come here when my wife was pregnant
they said santana was a great clinic to
deliver the baby
we immediately fell in love with the
ghana with the chino which in our
opinion is the best place in the world
to live
especially with young children to raise
in the meantime their children
have become three
all born in the saint anna's clinic and
while he goes back and forth from russia
his family lives permanently in paradiso
one of the largest companies worldwide
for these consumer products
a company with 6 000 employees and only
in russia
we work all over the world we
manufacture in different countries but
we sell in russia or in the eastern
countries ukraine belarus pakistan
with our management we do strategy
sessions and we always play some extreme
sports like climbing or rafting then in
the evening we talk about strategy
is the typical entrepreneur who made his
fortune after the collapse of the soviet
union
in the 1990s along with three partners
he created a cosmetics and home products
company call gradient
which has become the number one in this
field and is now listed among the 200
largest russian companies
soccer has been my lifelong passion
since i was born
i was born in kiev
from a very young age i used to play
with friends
i played soccer
i had the famous players as jerseys and
everything
then we moved to moscow and played for
dynamo moscow until the age of 14.
when max started playing soccer he was
taken in lugano's team
i saw how they trained and thought i
could improve the level of what i saw
i wanted to help
i submitted a pilot project to the club
with a slightly different approach a
little more ambitious and more
professional
now
next step was to ask angelo renzetti
president of lugano team to entrust him
with the entire youth department paying
1 million a year of his own money half
of the budget in exchange for the
guarantee that he would decide alone
this is how the new project started
we want everyone to be involved we can't
do it all alone working as a team will
engage young people
michelle
michelle
is a former professor at the university
of leuven in belgium where some 15 years
ago several brain research led him to
invent a cognitive training method
called corgi training which he exported
all over the world michelle is only the
first of world renowned great
specialists brought to conorerro by
leonid novoselski
i have noticed that many kids are not
using their feet properly when they
exercise
first make them run forward on this
white line then
when they run backwards wash them
if they don't rest their feet on the
line well it means that their balance
and their body control are not yet fully
developed
you need to adjust it ball to the ground
cord straight and to the hip hold it
like this
not
having noticed how amazed i was
michelle invited me to take a test and
explain to me what this strange ball
hang from a thread is for
i think about pushing it back and forth
check the images if you like
i'm not moving my hand
you can try it too there is nothing
spectacular
we shall not forget that our body is
full of energy focus on the movement
i'm concentrating to make it move from
left to right
now change back and forth
i have to try to move the ball using the
power of thought
according to michelle the trust that
comes from the brain can move an object
without using the muscles
incredible
this explains that everything we do
through the brain is determined by a
rhythm
this means that when we focus all the
energy on the ball we enter metronome
principles
[Music]
this ball attached to a thread is the
basic tool of the cookie training it is
the secret of the great leap and quality
of belgium football and has been
successfully adopted by the ac milan
youth teams and many other big european
clubs
i decided to follow michelle to belgium
to try to find out more
[Music]
as well
yes it is an amazing experience for me
when i met michelle in front of the gang
stadium where he started this new
training method he told me that a
delegation from the united arab emirates
would join us too
the delegation was attracted by this
program that got some of the gank youth
into national or foreign clubs
the results can be spectacular you'll
see
[Music]
[Music]
um
so there is always a brain activity
why do they force them to count
because this is blocking a specific part
of the brain that we call prefrontal
cortex
all technical gestures must be automated
you can't use them consciously
when the prefrontal cortex is active
other thoughts enter the brain
we get distracted
and it's over
you can see in this exercise that they
are obliged to stick to synchronization
they will never be able to do something
alone
in football you have to control where
your teammates are the opponent the ball
where you are on the pitch
players are supposed to do many things
at the same time
[Music]
is not only the use of the sense ball
but also includes a series of other
exercises in which every physical
movement is associated with reasoning
according to michelle brunix the
oxygenation of the brain helps
assimilating concepts and patterns
during learning processes speech and
time are major importance nothing is
done in life without the influence of
time
if you don't respect your brain's clock
you'll have problems
for example children with attention
disorders or who are hyperactive are not
able to manage the functioning of their
brain brain functioning is regulated by
time
if i understand correctly
these exercises don't only perfect
soccer technique but also reinforce
concentration and memorization this is
why implementing koji training is not
restricted to the soccer field alone
michelle wanted me to visit an
elementary school in the outskirt of
lush and female
where this method is being experimented
in a traditional
in french lessons you'll learn the
endings of the imperfect with koji
training
yesterday
play
[Music]
calculations and timetables
it will only help four five or even ten
children improve their performance it
will already be a success
we have done two days of training with
michelle brunix and since january we've
been implementing this method of brain
connection in classes as well
[Music]
concerning the origin of the name lugano
there are several theories from the god
name of celtic luke protector of the
waters from the latin medieval lagminus
inhibitions on lake
it helped me concentrate a lot in
training so i tried to do the same with
my homework
i found out that it worked so i
continued and it's going very well
does your teacher know that you do
exercise with the synthol while you
study at home
i don't think she knows but she knows i
have a secret method so to speak but i
haven't told her yet
and is in fifth grade in soduno
for a year and a half almost every day
he has been going back and forth between
la cardinal and coronado for his
training sessions
i wake up in the morning and i go to
school then in the afternoon as soon as
the doorbell rings i run downstairs
if it's a training day
i get in the car and go to lugano
and get changed in the car
when we arrive i get off and go to
training
i come back in the evening i get home at
about 8 15 8 20 p.m
i have dinner right away
then before i go to bed i still have
half an hour or 20 minutes
if i have something to do for school
some unfinished homework maybe i do that
otherwise i get rest on the couch
then i go to sleep and my day ends
it's very tiring at the beginning it was
much more but now i got used to it
and how are your grades in school
my grades are very good
i have all these except for 3d minuses
i'm very happy with my life because my
dream as a small child was to make a
goal against barcelona i was lucky
enough to play there and manage to make
my dream come true
the first stop is
to pick up ron
who is 12 and is in the sixth grade in
minuso
both kids at leonid novoselski's request
have left the cardinal team to go and
play with lugano
i used to play with ilya
in the locarno team then in january we
went to play with lugano
the training here is more specific
unlike with lugano in lugano we train
four times a week for one and a half
hours or two and it's very intensive
this way we improve every time
then you play saturdays and sundays
it's always either friendlies or
international tournaments
what is your dream
first of all wearing the lugano jersey
of the major team and being able to play
international matches on a very high
level
national
if the threat isn't taught it means you
are not focused ready go
the marking of time and space the
synchronization that they have
are of the greatest importance for their
concentration
this is a tool that we use especially in
pre-workouts and pre-match because we
notice it brings the kids especially in
their approach to the game to develop a
very high level of concentration
[Music]
amarillo
we speak spanish
barcelona coaches arrive on the field
in modern football they are considered
among the best coaches in the world
we want to work with the best in the
world and if you have the chance to work
with the best in the world you too can
reach if not the best a very high level
novelties never end
after the belgian method of misha
bronics and the forefront of spanish
soccer a real world guru of soccer
arrived in lugano
a former american soccer player
also very well known in asia
after he made soccer popular in japan he
is now attempting to raise the level of
chinese soccer
tom byer is famous for his approach
towards working with very small children
when i say very small i mean the newborn
you know i work in china
i work in china where there are 100
million children under the age of six
in china they hired the best coaches in
the world lippy
capello sven ericsson they hired them
fired and rehired but so far they had
the wrong approach because they had
neglected to work with younger children
and their families
it's on them you should concentrate if
you want to have the best players and
change the world of soccer
all right so i'm going to show you my
son
now i'll show you my two-year-old son
he has a small ball a small foot and he
is in a tight environment and i
encourage him to send the ball back and
forth right foot left foot is like a toy
he plays in his environment i only
discourage him to kick he shouldn't kick
and discouraging kicking no kicking no
kicking no
why uh no kicking okay
why is it better not to kick
i'll show you why
this is a park an open space
if i let him kick he'll soon learn move
the ball away
instead of protecting it and keeping it
between his defeat which is more fun
he's small and his legs are short he can
stay in a small space if i encourage him
to kick he will run after the ball and
won't improve he'll get tired right away
and stop
[Music]
time span from one up to five years is
much more important before entering into
a professional club how can you do that
only by involving and educating families
because the context at home football at
home this is the idea
football at home
we have to find the right way to engage
these families
i still don't know how we're going to do
that we'll look for ways to explain to
convince help educate families who have
this dream that their children could
become players
and those who will start at the age of 1
will have more possibilities than the
others
[Music]
during the first training session mr
leonida novoselsky introduced himself
and explained the whole project
and we loved it he told me i want to win
against juventus against chelsea
he said i want to play
no he said i want to win
i want lugano to win against chelsea
against juventus
and manchester city
i thought this man is crazy how can our
children win against chelsea
but it's been five six months
they worked with their coaches all
together as a team
we went and we won against chelsea 2-1
against juventus 2-0 this year we also
won against liverpool and we tied
they won two or three times we tied with
great teams like milan
genoa
torino
we're back in vienna where things are
getting serious
the tourists we had left in the city
center in front of saint stephen's
cathedral will take to the field today
for an under nine tournament of high
international level
the nice thing about these tournaments
and of this tournament in particular
it's not given to everyone to experience
such a thing so enjoy this tournament
play with a smile and play with the
right grit
if we'll make mistakes it will still
mean we tried okay kids
[Music]
in italy is considered the number one
coach for training eight or nine year
old players
after successfully working for atlanta
he moved to ac milan before joining
lugano
my son played with stella capriasca and
then he wanted to go to lugano he
started at the soccer school down in
kona retro and his coach wanted him in
his team he is the only one born in 2010
in this team he's the youngest he is the
smurf of the team and makes us very
proud
my kids played in italy we are italian
and they played in the pro patria
imbusto arcizio very good
but we really liked the lugano project
above all the fact that this year's
coach biffy would be in charge
it's the first experience abroad for our
boys they only did it last weekend
that's understandable they're prevailing
we can't seem to build a game
[Music]
we have to fight with the strong not the
weak
the young players fought bravely but
ended the vienna tournament in the 11th
place out of 12 participating teams
so kids the level of this tournament was
pretty high but are you happy
yes
what did you learn from these matches
that you must never give up and you must
never get distracted
[Music]
we tell them these matches are for
training because our match is the
champions league final and the world cup
final
there where we go with you
we want our players to get into that
level